instead of developers accessing your
backend services directly
they can be exposed through api proxies
on apigee
which are http endpoints the proxy
manages any code changes on the backend
and avoids disruptions for developers
until a new version of the api is
warranted
an api proxy enables you to apply
security features
enforce access limits and quotas provide
caching
create transformations and handle errors
it also lets you perform monitoring
and create analytic reports you usually
group
multiple api proxies into an api product
and
offer that as a service plan for example
you may want to provide an api product
for free up to a certain request limit
per day for developers to try out your
api
but we'll cover that in another episode
you will have
some flexibility when creating your api
proxy and so
to get started in this episode i will
walk you through how to build your first
api proxy
[Music]
before getting started you will need to
have configured access to your api proxy
either externally
or internally i have linked instructions
in this video
called accessing api proxies
next visit the apigee console at
apigee.google.com
then develop api proxies
then select create new this will prompt
the proxy wizard
and you will choose reverse proxy
next enter the following values for the
proxy name proxy base path
description and the target existing api
then click next and apigee will create
your proxy
next choose to visit the api proxy list
so that we can deploy
our proxy by returning to develop
api proxies again next ensure you are
on your eval environment by looking at
the top otherwise
use the drop down to change environments
click on my proxy then notice that under
deployments the revision column shows
not deployed next from the revision drop
down choose one
as this is the first version and then
click deploy
after a few seconds pass you can see
from the status bar
when your proxy is fully deployed
now you can test the api proxy by using
the command line terminal
as a friendly reminder if you haven't
configured access to your proxies either
internally or externally i have linked
instructions
on how to do that note that in my case
the external ip provided by an external
load balancer
is registered with a dns registered
hostname
next if the call succeeds you will see
the hello guest has the output now let's
try changing the target
endpoint to output xml so let's return
to develop
api proxies again select your desired
proxy
then on the top far right click develop
which will take you to the api proxy
editor
which lets you see the structure of your
api proxy and configure its flow
in the navigator pane select target
endpoints
preflow on the code pane you can spot
your target url
endpoint next append forward slash xml
to the existing url
so that it looks like this next click
save
you'll be asked to save it as a new
revision since you already deployed
revision 1
and that can't be changed then deploy to
the new revision by selecting the button
deploy to eval and choose deploy to
test your changes by sending a request
to your proxy via command line
just like we did earlier like this and
this should return xml
now let's add a policy to convert that
xml into json
we will use an xml to json policy in the
proxy response flow
this policy converts the payload of an
xml message
to json it also changes the response's
content type header
to add the xml to json policy to your
proxy let's return to api
proxies develop
select your desired proxy then on the
top far right click develop
this time click proxy endpoints
default preflow to add a policy to your
proxy
click the plus step button in the
response preflow
the bottom half of the flow editor
apogee displays a categorized list of
policies in the ad
dialog box that you can add to your flow
scroll down and select
the xml to json policy leave the default
names and click add
apigee attaches the new policy to the
pre-flow of the response which does
three things
one it adds the new policy under
policies in the navigator pane
two it adds the xml to json policy in
the flow pane
and three it displays the policies
configuration xml in the code pane
we'll just use the default configuration
that's suggested but this can be
customized
next click save and test it out with the
following curl command
congrats you've successfully added the
xml to json policy to your new proxy
as the next step i have linked in this
video's description
more information on how to add
additional functionality to your api
proxies
if you're interested in the next episode
i will walk you through
how to apply apogee security policies to
your proxy
so stay tuned and friends if you found
this episode helpful
you can click like or subscribe to the
channel cheers
[Music]